gracias por ver otro vídeo de educación
sexual advertencia este vídeo contiene
referencias a agresiones sexuales y
otros temas sensibles todos en este
vídeo se hicieron la prueba de kobe 19
alguna vez has tenido sentimientos por
una coestrella o sexo fuera de cámara
si esta será buena le pedimos a nuestra
audiencia que enviar a sus preguntas
sexuales más íntimas que extraños les
responderían basándose en sus
experiencias con cuántas personas has
tenido sexo sueles ver porno por placer
alguna vez has tenido sentimientos por
una co estrella o sexo fuera de cámara
educación sexual estrellas porno
con cuántas personas has tenido sexo
llevas la cuenta o radios no creo que
más de 100 personas digo creo que no es
mucho verdad no lo sé
perdí la perspectiva tengo una lista en
el teléfono móvil justo ahora son 69 lo
siento chicos no tengo idea
al inicio estaba orgulloso pero ahora me
avergüenza decirlo porque tienes tanto
sexo es literal ver a alguien y decirle
hola mucho gusto y digan como no ya
tuvimos sexo y responder o lo siento
mucho qué tan diferente es tu vida
sexual personal de lo que muestras en
cámara mi vida sexual fuera de cámara es
mucho más íntima como poder tocarlos y
sentirlos en mi pecho y cosas así no
tener que preocuparme de que la cámara
captura toda la acción pues claro que
disfrutas el sexo y quieres disfrutarlo
pero al final del día todo esa actuación
90% de lo que hago en cámara no lo
quiero en mi habitación no voy a
balancear me como tarzán y caer con una
voltereta hacia atrás no haré nada de
eso si se siente bien y tú sientes que
quieres terminar lo haces en grabaciones
es tipo espera aún faltan dos posiciones
más es como tener sexo en reversa me
posiciono en buenos ángulos para que se
vea la luz y la cámara capte lo que lo
que sucede no estás en un espacio
privado y personal mi vida sexual es
mucho más íntima y es más sobre sentir
que lo que se ve tal vez puedes llorar
durante el sexo o tal vez solo sentirte
muy vulnerable al hacerlo no es una
situación que suele frecuentar en cuanto
a mi pornografía porque no es seguro que
la gente quiera ver eso la mayoría sólo
quiere ver sexo
tendrás buen sexo en el set pero así no
tienes como llegar al punto de conocer a
la otra persona íntimamente puede salir
ir a comer puedes tomar unos tragos y el
poder conocerlos esa experiencia la
disfrutas entonces y solo si quieres y
aquí está la diferencia si quieres tener
sexo lo haces como afectado a tu trabajo
a tu vida sexual la arruina do you know
siento que mi trabajo me dio
superpoderes gracias a eso soy muy
abierta así es más fácil llegar a ese
punto en la relación para romper todas
esas barreras sexuales y saltar a lo
realmente divertido al comienzo de mi
carrera tenía esta mentalidad donde
pensaba si no me pagan para tener sexo
entonces no lo haré es mi profesión
ahora soy profesional y cuando ejerces
tu profesión te pagan por eso siempre y
luego me enamoré
bueno
esto no es algo que las personas esperen
pero de hecho soy asexual yo no tengo
una vida sexual activa en general es
como si tu pareja le gusta el fútbol ya
ti no así que vas a un juego con ellos
en ocasiones pero no es como si fueras a
partidos de fútbol solo muy seguido fue
una gran decisión para mí anunciar que
soy asexual por eso puedes perder muchos
suscriptores y seguidores es decir toda
esta noción de la industria para adultos
es de hacer una fantasía y esta es
destruida cuando le dices a la gente que
no te interesa [ __ ] con ellos
empiezo a creer que soy asexual porque a
estas alturas no quiero tener sexo con
una dije creo que he perdido la
sensibilidad y no no sé qué decirles de
verdad pero yo empecé en la industria
sexual a los 18 y comencé siendo una
dama de compañía entonces tenía sexo con
casi seis hombres al día y ahora que
tengo 23
creo que he llegado a un límite cuando
es sobre sexo se necesita mucho para
ponerme caliente y creo que está
relacionado con tener tantas parejas
sexuales cuando era más joven bueno sí
creo que creo que es eso con qué
frecuencia el sexo en cámara es de
verdad placentero para ti los orgasmos
son reales era muy inusual y ni siquiera
puedo diferenciar cuándo fue real por
qué estaba tan concentrada en la
actuación siendo honesta diría que un 40
por ciento
pensaba que tenía que fingir lo solo
entraba y hacía como
tomate
lo que quiero responder es sí sí sí
cuando veo porno puedo notar si la gente
no conecta y eso no me calienta para mí
y me coestrella a la hora de trabajar
debemos tener una conexión me atrevo a
decir que en casi cada una de mis
escenas tuve un orgasmo real no voy a
traerte al set para no tener un orgasmo
no perder ese tiempo después soy un
hombre así que tengo que llegar al
orgasmo si no no me pagan sí no es
terminar lo falsificaran así que tendrás
un tubo con el que puedes disparar semen
falso en todas mis filmaciones tienen en
algún punto una pausa comer o tomar agua
algo que pueda subirnos el ánimo sueles
ver porno por placer o se siente como
trabajo consumo porno todo el tiempo y
ahora con el cover bromeó pero es verdad
no puede ser de un estudio porno si yo
sé que breakers o ebook angels lo hizo
no lo voy a ver tiene que ser de
aficionados tengo que creer que fue real
esta es graciosa la razón de que no veo
porno es porque soy asexual solo no
tengo ningún interés en ver eso mis
coestrellas son gente atractiva pero no
lo sé me siento rara viéndolos tener
sexo
es como filmar con esta persona mañana
me tomaré un café con esta persona es
como si vieras a tu primo tener sexo y
no quieres ver a tu primo tener sexo
cuando ve una porno yo tiendo a juzgar a
los chicos pero qué haces solo
bloqueando no puedo ver qué sucede
cambiar el vídeo el chico obstruye la
vista
solo veo mis propias escenas para
criticarme y es todo por placer yo suelo
ver mis vídeos porque recuerdo las
sensaciones y lo que sentía si si lo
hago pero es algo muy raro los veo para
asegurarme que lo hice bien como visible
para gente que intenta
a encender un fuego
como te proteges de la css y del
embarazo se de chicas que usan
anticonceptivos y se de otras que no los
usan y no filman cuando están ovulando
nos hacemos pruebas tan seguido
en cada 14 días y algunas veces es
incluso más frecuente que 14 días y no
quiere decir que no nos den las pequeñas
infecciones bacterianas una que otra vez
es parte del trabajo pero intentamos ser
muy cuidadosos con el set son de sexo
seguro así que soy solo preservativo
limpiamos los sets y también he ido a
sets que dan mucho miedo no voy a
mentirles pero en sets que yo uso y
donde filmó nos aseguramos de que todo
esté limpio y que todo sea cómodo alguna
vez has tenido sentimientos por una
cuesta ya o sexo fuera de cámara
si
esta será buena la mayoría de las
personas son muy sensuales y solo sucede
si fue de hecho el primer chico con el
que filme bueno y estuve tan enamorada
de él estaba asombrada en la forma en
que se me abalanzó
he visto varios problemas entre parejas
o si los celos siempre sucede si la
persona no está filmando con su pareja o
de repente la persona que trabaja en
esto no quiere que su pareja siga
haciendo más porno no lo creo mi trabajo
este tiempo completo y es un gran alivio
el poder estar con alguien que me
distrae de eso un poco cuál es la peor
parte del trabajo siempre le digo esto a
la gente no cambiaría nada sobre mi
trabajo cambiaría la forma en que la
sociedad de mi trabajo se de chicas que
tienen un nuevo apartamento al que se
mudan y los vecinos se enteran de que
trabajan y ellos envían sus fotos a todo
el edificio tipo esa chica es 'por no
tengan cuidado con ella y cosas así eso
de verdad sucede la mayoría y el mundo
odian la pornografía y no estoy seguro
que algún día me acepten además del
hecho de ser un hombre que tiene vagina
eso está en otro nivel pero lo que hago
es luchar en su contra el porno no sería
una industria tan grande si la gente no
la consumiera es lo que he estado
intentando decirle al mundo la sociedad
aún no acepta el entretenimiento de
adultos y eso limita lo que puedo hacer
con mi futuro
soy violinista y una de mis metas era
dirigir una orquesta de escuela algún
día ya no puedo hacer eso es algo que ya
sacrifiqué mi próxima entrevista de
trabajo luego de esto podrían rechazar
me solo porque me pueden ver desnuda en
internet
como manejan el consentimiento dentro
del set muy importante amo esta pregunta
gracias por hacerla al principio el
porno no era sobre el consentimiento no
había este régimen y reglas que tenemos
hoy la gente se reunía tenía sexo si la
chica no quería anal lástima lo vas a
hacer eso sucedía más de lo que piensan
eso ya no suele suceder tanto cuando
estás en set hay una lista de control de
lo que estás de acuerdo y hablas con él
con el director y tu pareja amo el
consentimiento y creo que es creo que es
muy sensual eso en un es en el otro día
el chico estaba como puedo hacer esto tu
vagina y yo puedo hacerle esto a tu pene
me piden que haga muchas cosas muy muy
extrañas e indignantes la lista no
parece terminar juegos de rol sobre raza
o violaciones no los voy a aceptar
recibí muchas
órdenes específicas de supremacistas
blancos aplicó la filosofía del
consentimiento entusiasta y a menos que
esté de verdad entusiasmada por eso solo
no lo hago has tenido experiencias donde
tal vez tus límites fueron cruzados de
hecho sí y creo que jugué un papel
importante en eso porque no sabía cómo
hacer para establecer mis límites o no
tenía claro cuáles eran esos límites y
tenía aceptar a todos sin siquiera
preguntar qué es lo que implica si me
paso y yo sentí que fue una trampa lo
más loco es que estaba emocionada por
filmar con ellos porque es una de las
compañías más grandes de porno y me
sentía cómoda como bien la maquillista
hasta aquí la otra asistente aquí si hay
mujeres en el set muy atentas y luego
con el director comenzamos a tomar fotos
y luego todo se quedó callado mire al
director y le pregunté dónde están las
chicas y dijo ellas se fueron y cuando
empezamos la filmación él era tan
brusco y yo soy víctima de violación así
que las
cosas que él hacía con mi cuerpo solo no
respondía ahí
fue muy doloroso tener sexo con él al
llegar a casa solo estaba estaba agotada
y exhausta y me encerré en mi habitación
como por dos días porque no podía creer
lo que me sucedió te ha preocupado como
la industria porno representa el sexo si
la mayor crítica que tengo sobre el
industria porno es que carece de sentido
de intimidad sentido de realidad mi
opinión puede ser controversial pero
creo que las páginas gratis son dañinas
el mundo del porno gratis está
exponiendo
escenas y es tan fácil que niños
consigan estas páginas y que aprendan de
vídeos porno para mí como artista me
gustaría ver sexo más realista en lugar
de algo como hola soy tiffany y luego
iniciar el sexo anal entienden es
fantasía y no realista no ven el detrás
de escena el acuerdo entre parejas en el
set y desearía que como estrellas del
porno seamos más
francos y decir cosas como oye
consentimos hacer esto no está bien
elegir a cualquier chica de un bar y
escupir la y darle una gran cachetada
siento que el porno es mucho más
violento las mujeres siempre sumisa y
solo creo que esto es a raíz de tanto
odio a las mujeres y la misoginia que la
mujer tiene que hacer lo que el hombre
quiere y hacerlo sentir bien creo que la
industria porno se está volviendo más
diversa y estoy emocionada por ver como
plataformas como un live and tren de
vuelta a la realidad al contenido
adultos producimos para ti el consumidor
que quiere verlo de ninguna forma
queremos que los niños lo vean no
pensamos que sea educativo es fantasía
es diversión para mí mi trabajo siempre
ha sido activismo entonces publicamos
eso diciendo miren disfruto mi vida y
también el sexo a otros les gusta verme
tener sexo es algo consensuado entre
adultos que pasan un buen rato y te lo
dan a ti para que lo disfrutes viendo
también eso no me preocupa pero pienso
que mientras más hablemos de eso habrá
menos estigma
suscríbete a más educación sexual
quieres aparecer en un vídeo suscríbete
a nuestro newsletter de castings jubilee
puntocom envía preguntas para nuevos
episodios
jubilee media síguenos y jubilee media
sex.com